foreign
[Music]
Hope You Dance as well as you dress
there's only one way to find out
[Music]
you and I we're not so different agent
Argyle
little help hold on
[Music]
phenomenal sweetie but
what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Kelly it's called a
cop-out
[Music]
oh hey there's a cat in there
oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
oh yeah what is it you do Espionage
would you sign my book
here we go
I love this book
come on
[Music]
who are these people real life spies why
would they care about me because you're
a goddamn fortune teller really
when you wrote in your new book actually
happened and you Kicked the Hornets Nest
you didn't even know existed I made some
really big trouble mom
I want all assets on them now I need her
to write the next chapter
God I hate that cat that cat
[Music]
it's time for you to meet the real agent
Argyle
oh my God oh my God oh my God